hey guys markiplier here back with
another episode of crooked man I've been
trying to get this working for a while
it got to the point where I had to look
up a walkthrough and it seemed like it
would have been obvious but it actually
was totally not I have to okay this is
actually quite complicated because I
never would have thought of this on my
own I have no idea how I would have made
this leap to conclusions because for
some reason I thought that all these
bottles were empty when we made this but
when in fact they're actually here's a
monster again hi I've been through this
like 10 times trying to figure this out
I was trying to record this hi hello I
dropped you down a peg crap I gotta do
something what you have to do is you
have to smash him over the head with
this bottle which apparently is full of
alcohol then you uh you use the lighter
he's covered in alcohol he should be
plenty flammable yeah that yeah that
that that totally I apologize for
looking at the walkthrough but uh I just
gotta admit that this guy is just a
stone-cold badass he smashes him with a
bottle of brandy and then lights him on
fire who would think to do that to a
monster that is currently chasing that's
absolutely badass anyway it's been a
very long day for me and I've been
yelling a lot today on some great shoots
that I've been doing um I was at the
YouTube space all day
all day today that's a I need to look
some for something to defend myself with
okay alright so that's my next on my
objective and it was just really really
fun to be able to do this because I had
an entire crew a director of photography
an audio guy um a grip it was just all
sorts of really cool interesting stuff
in the videos that we made are gonna be
amazing
well them either they're rather silly
probably but I still think they're funny
anyway I some time I'm not even gonna
pretend like I didn't see that I told me
to pick up the knife in the walkthrough
ma'am a fruit knife this is a knife that
I saw before and I wanted to take with
me maybe I should take it just for
self-defense now it's been amazing being
out here in LA being surrounded but in
all honesty right now I've been
for so long then I want nothing more
than just to be back at home and making
videos for you guys again because um I
mean I just really love making videos
for you guys and just entertaining is
that blood on the floor over there
oh it's leading me somewhere but anyway
I sincerely just like making videos for
you guys and being out here and doing
creative stuff is really cool but at the
same time it's it's a lot of extra work
for stuff and I want to put a lot of
work into videos that I do personally oh
my god I can't even walk through this
blood but blood this wasn't here earlier
anyway all I'm trying to say is it I
sincerely appreciate all you guys who
watch me every day and keep up with me
and and without you guys I wouldn't have
the opportunity to come over here to LA
and be able to do this sort of stuff so
sincerely from the bottom of my heart
thank you anyway back to the game I've
been blabbering about stuff that you
probably don't care about so anyway
there's blood here I need to is that
going - oh no okay it's going over here
I'm guessing I'm gonna have some sort of
showdown with this monster I don't know
how its bleeped oh maybe that's not the
monsters blood
maybe that's sissy's blood okay well
seems to be putting up in here the door
is unlocked oh oh oh that's [ __ ] on the
bed over there but I have a bad feeling
about this did uh some monster that was
completely on fire coming nah do
something to you [ __ ] what are you
doing here your arms bleeding so it was
your blood were you hurt ah yeah my arm
caught on something it's not that big a
deal how about it caught on the claw of
a monster come on you have anemia I'm
just a little tired I've been walking
around a lot and you're bleeding
everywhere I'm worried I'm worried about
you [ __ ] give me your hand [ __ ] that's
a silly name I know it's a real name it
I've Anchorage if I can at least try to
wrap you up
I come here [ __ ] give me that bleeding
arm I guess this is better than nothing
doesn't hurt it's fine thank you you're
so kind David oh they're romanticizing
you don't seem so well did something
happen well I saw this giant flaming
fireball of
yes it was interesting it's nothing I
just been so silly wandering around
falling in holes cutting my arm all to
find some measly box it's important a
memento from your boyfriend huh he's my
ex to be exact
huh mmm he left me quite a while ago but
while we were dating this hotel with our
special place that was when I lost the
box and then worried about it ever since
but I only just worked up the courage to
come look I thought I could forget
everything about him but it was no good
coming here brought back all the
memories why did you break up I've got a
feeling but I mentioned later I don't
know maybe that's why I won't give up
he said he appreciated my kindness but
when we broke up he said it was all I
had and he was exactly right so I
couldn't reply I really am a wimp
no wonder he'd break up with me even I'd
hate a girl like me sorry I know I'm
just annoying you I'll rest here for a
while longer I'm a little dizzy thanks
for your help David oh I found this I'm
not sure where it goes though a key to
somewhere don't strain yourself okay
[ __ ] well I'm going alright I have a
theory because obviously the notes
they'd been reading obviously he's
mentioning this girl because there was
this guy that has a special place up in
the mountains with the hotel this is her
so she's obviously what who's talking
excuse me
why am I was like what like what you're
always such a yes-man just going with
the flow don't you have a personality I
don't mean to I mean I think I try to
think for myself I don't see it that way
coz I'm a dick
oh I'm a I'm a [ __ ] you're not kind
you're just indecisive it would be the
same with anyone but me right that's why
I can't trust you
look please just listen I'm always
thinking of you if I'm a pain that I'm
sorry there you go again thinking you
can just apologize and everything will
be fine you don't understand a word I'm
saying
then what should I do
you don't trust me is that it it's
hopeless for us I hate for it to end
this way but it would just be an
annoyance for us both to stay together
any longer
thanks for everything David goodbye
well that's pretty douchey well wait we
can talk this out surely surely we can
talk this out don't call me Shirley
you're playing joke kindness is all you
have [ __ ] and I are the same like that
timidly refusing to forget well is that
so well aren't you just souls from a
different era the moment I realized she
didn't love me I felt like I was nothing
but worthless
I wondered if [ __ ] felt that way too
what oh I'm playing now again I heard
wind was whistling rustling through the
wind hmm
something strange is going on in this
place it doesn't seem right I still
can't walk through this blood it's no
permanent obstacle you know it's been a
while since I use this blue yeti
microphone and it's very strange to me
how much better the microphones I have
now is compared to this I mean I'm
always popping with this one anyway I
need I'm blabbering about you don't care
about again key used for somewhere
unknown so I'm just gonna I'm just gonna
go through these doors again no not for
that one it may have been um for the
door that was beside the door where I
went into the owners area and where I
first encountered the monster might be
here ah there we go okay I had a theory
about that one okay so I'm saving
spastically because I don't know what
the monsters gonna pop out again
something's in the fountain oh it's a
box it's sissy's box but this is gonna
reveal something about [ __ ] it's a one
oh this is me fishing it out it's must
be it's decorated with rubbers did
someone throw it away here or what man
I'm glad I found it I'll give this to
Susie Bronto but it won't turn out that
way because I know how these horror
games turn out
hello mr. monster man how you doing okay
all right which room hallway blood led
to it [ __ ]
oh no huh did [ __ ] leave but she's
wounded because she's not really there
okay [ __ ] got yelled and just being
attacked oh oh oh oh oh what with the
scream come from where the scream come
from is that the piano oh my oh
yeah [ __ ] there's a bit of a whoa
Delinda Lee hey you [ __ ] you can mess
with her I'm the strategy guide suck on
that man I'm a badass I am some sort of
a bomb hi friend how you doing old buddy
damn it
[ __ ] get out of the hotel David what
are you I said run I'll take care of
this cuz damn this guy's awesome King
hey you [ __ ] I don't know what the hell
you are
don't you lay a finger on [ __ ]
Danton oh it's gonna make me say because
obviously there's gonna be a fight to
the death
oh oh I have a health bar how do i oh z
okay get ready to be yeah yeah oh wait I
can't live get that closer yeah yeah
yeah oh yeah geez dude I love the piano
music they got going on here you like
bring it on bring it on
oh I thought I got yeah yeah whoa boy he
gets a little burst of speed yeah
oh no I'm one head from death the old
timey ragtime aah game over let's try
not to start a new game this time how
about that game oh really
Crooked Man now I know how to beat you
maybe yeah but I move so quick like I
accidentally run into him okay
ah does he have a health bar I don't
know ah wait that oh come on I actually
did it up and down dude ah boom
come on don't be [ __ ] this one up I'm
talking all come on I like run one more
space and I want to run it's really
annoying
yeah I'm gonna die no no how much
healthy takes did it did sir there's a
silliest battle I've ever seen in my
life
ah oh did I get him did I get him
oh I thought I didn't get him oh I got
him David oh you boss you manly man you
mountain of muscle then actually make
love to you right here pant pant David
are you okay yeah I don't think it'll
chases anymore baby never mind me are
you okay bear braver I'm fine I'm not
hurt but Oh [ __ ] what's wrong are you
sick why why did this happen why did I
have to go through this
why did a monster attack me
thank you thank you what about me I just
didn't want to forget him
I didn't want to I just want to have my
memory of him is it because I'm such a
wimp is that why this happened
can I can I not even love him no I hate
it
somebody somebody help uh who you
talking to
I'm right here [ __ ] baby hey whoa what
was that
what but why do I have a choice here
wait what
what's wrong with a will huh baby
Woodrow we really will what is wrong
with being a woman I'm curious but I
haven't saved in a while I mean it's
easy enough to be the boss again which
one do I peg you like one rather than a
whip which are we being a wimp no sister
no sir no sir
you may feel like a [ __ ] for not being
able to forget him but is that such a
bad thing David I was dumped a few
months ago too
I'm sure we were going to get married
you too I was dejected even now it still
pains me I don't think I could truly
forget it I've always hated I was such a
coward I'm a miserable excuse for a man
especially in romance and especially in
bed I couldn't even be happy when my
friend got married and it made me hate
myself more and more but looking at you
I've come to think maybe it's not bad to
think of me keep thinking of the same
person in fact maybe it's a wonderful
very creepy thing uh-huh uh-huh I've
decided I wouldn't give up either and
it's thanks to you she's he thank you
David I mean David this is your treasure
right it's quite the box to be it's be
ashamed to throw it away
take good care of it okay I am sure the
one you love will understand and I know
I'll always support you
thank you David I'll try a little harder
I hope things go well for you too
hey David oh boy the music dropout did
the box come with the key a key no I
didn't see one strange the box needs a
key to open so though I didn't lock it
huh what wait hold on I have a key
I got a brass key hey what do you know
yes has a one where did you find how do
you know it's a right key I picked it up
around here or did you a key from my
house open sissy's box as a former
tenants involved with the box or his
sissy's boyfriend wonder why it was
locked let's open it and unlock what
horribly evil these weeds oh there's a
piece of paper that's [ __ ] can I look
at that I thought so it matches the
notebook pages which means he I don't
get it but I guess the guy you're
looking forward to put this paper in
here seems that way it has an address on
it are you going there David yeah he
wasn't here so I'll check there next
okay be careful
dun-dun-duh I'll escort you home Susie
it's dark out after all I'll be alright
thanks so David well one last goodbye
kiddo
no hey how's that startled me for a
second I thought it was gonna be
something else I'm really thankful David
let's see each other again sometime
okay that that surprised me huh
but she seems happier now that's good I
feel a little more relaxed myself
interesting lingering scent of dreams is
this where he is I'll go check it
out I've come this far until I see him
I'll go anywhere hmm
scene one over a good job everybody
oh man I'm really liking this story I
mean walking mechanics aside it's still
a really interesting story I'm very
curious as to what's going I'm gonna say
VIN data - because it was a choice made
I don't know what the other one led to
maybe maybe I'm going down a completely
different game path I have no idea so
anyway that'll Oh
hold your horses everybody put your
pants back on
zip up your fly put the [ __ ] away let's
go oh well this looks sinister man this
place was far that took almost all day
so this is a place looks like the school
was abandoned no one around though I
guess they'd be inside anyway
oh really inside an abandoned school
let's take a look haha
all right so whoops man 83 whatever all
right so that's all the time I got for
now if you know what happened that I
missed maybe you can put a comment in
the comment section below and let me
know anyway
sincerely guys now that I have time to
talk to you guys if you've been making
it this far
I really am grateful for you guys
watching my videos and listen to me
every day and you know traveling out
like this it's it wears down on me a lot
because I've been traveling like for the
past few months I've been traveling
non-stop and I haven't been able to just
like really dedicate I mean outlast na
Monisha I explint sprinted through those
three videos today just because they
didn't want to be recording those on the
road but sincerely I'm really glad that
I can do this and come out here be
creative because some of these videos
that were making while we're here are
like some of the things that I
originally wanted to do on YouTube and
you know I really get a chance to be me
and be myself and you can skip this if
you if you don't want to hear me
rambling just skip to the next video if
it's already yet but sincerely guys I I
just want you guys to know how much
abrasion I appreciate your your
viewership and your dedication to the
community that we've been building in
and the efforts that we do for charity
and stuff like that and I've got a lot
of big plans in the future and I've got
a lot of big goals because I mean
we're gonna reach like a million in in
two months here and that's pretty insane
and I don't even know what to think of
but sincerely thank you guys so much for
watching and you know I I just felt like
I don't say that enough so thank you all
so much for watching click the
annotation for more videos that I've
done and as always I will see you in the
next video bye bye